لقد اقترحت هذا الأسبوع على
اللجنة البرلمانية أه أن إسرائيل
قد تكون مذنبة بارتكاب جرائم حرب أم لم أفعل لم أقل ذلك
أه حسنًا حسنًا
دعني أسألك بهذه الطريقة فهل
تتفق مع الجنوب أفريقيين
أن إسرائيل لديها قضية يجب الرد عليها أمام
محكمة العدل الدولية لا،
لا أعتقد ذلك على الإطلاق، أعتقد أن
الإجراء الذي اتخذته جنوب إفريقيا خاطئ، أعتقد أنه
غير مفيد، أعتقد أنه لا ينبغي أن
يحدث الآن بالطبع، أنت تعلم أنني
لست  محامٍ لكنهم يتحدثون هنا عن
الإبادة الجماعية، إنهم يتعاملون مع هذه القضية
على أساس الإبادة الجماعية وأنت تعلم أن
إثبات أنه يتعين عليك التحسن يجب أن
تثبت أن هناك نية الآن، كما تعلم أنني
أتبنى وجهة النظر القائلة بأن ذلك  إن
إسرائيل تتصرف دفاعاً عن النفس بعد
الهجوم المروع الذي وقع في 7
أكتوبر/تشرين الأول، ولكن حتى لو كان لديك
وجهة نظر مختلفة عن وجهة نظري، أم أن تنظر إلى إسرائيل، دولة
ديمقراطية، دولة تتمتع بسيادة القانون،
دولة لديها قوات مسلحة
ملتزمة  طاعة سيادة القانون
للقول إن لديهم تلك الدولة
تلك القيادة لتلك القوات المسلحة وأن
لديهم النية لارتكاب إبادة جماعية وأعتقد أن هذا
هراء وأعتقد أن هذا
خطأ ولكني لا أستطيع أن أعرف أنه لا
يمكنك الحكم إلا على  على أساس ما
فعلوه، نعم يمكنك الحكم،
ولكن يمكنك الحكم على أساس ما
فعلوه وكيف تصرفوا ولماذا
يتصرفون والقول بأن هناك
نية لارتكاب إبادة جماعية، أعتقد
ذلك